Merhabalar ben İlayda eskitaşçıoğlu
Konuşmamız gerek derneğinin eş
kurucularından biriyim ve Bugün sizinle
Türkiye'de kimsenin konuşmak istemediği
bir konu hakkında konuşmak için
buradayım
regloksulu ve reglusu
Konuşmamız gerek Derneği olarak 2016
yılından beri
regloksuluyla Ve re kitabı ile
Anadolu'nun dört bir köşesinde mücadele
ediyoruz Peki nedir bizim bu mücadele
ettiğimiz şey biraz ondan bahsedeyim
aslında regloksulluğu çok basit bir
tanım yapmamız gerekirse şöyle
tanımlanabilir
regl olan bireylerin Bu dönemlerde
kullanmaları gereken menstrual ürünlere
Örneğin hijyenike'de tampona
erişim sıkıntısı bu genellikle sosyal
ekonomik yetersizliklerden paranın bu
ürünleri almaya yetmemesinden
kaynaklanıyor ama aslında bakkaldan
parayla hijyenik hep alılamadan çok daha
öteye çok daha karmaşık bir problem
bunun farklı farklı boyutları Örneğin
temiz suya erişimsizlik temiz güvenli
bir tuvalete temiz kapalı alanlara
erişimsizlik Veya bizim çok Önem
verdiğimiz regl olmak ve ergenlik
konularında açık ve doğru bilgiye
erişimsizlik de regloksuzluğunun farklı
farklı boyutlarını oluşturuyor açıkçası
ve reg yoksulluğu deneyimiyle Aslında el
ele olan sımsıkı bağlı bir başka problem
de var Bizim savaştığımız O da RK
kitabusu Yani aslında çok normal bir
biyolojik deneyim olan reglin
utanılacak iğrenç kirli saklanılması
gereken bir şey gibi görünmesi ve asla
konuşulmaması Biz de bu yüzden aslında
inadına konuşmak için biraz garip bir
ayrılık konuşmasının ilk cümlesini
hatırlatan Konuşmamız gerek isimli
derneğimizi kurduk bu mücadelenin en
başına mücadelenin ve hikayenin nasıl
başladığına dönelim isterseniz bunun
için 2011 yılına geri dönmemiz gerekiyor
çoğunu satırlarsınız 2011 yılında
Türkiye'nin doğusunda Van merkezli büyük
bir deprem olmuştu ben de baba
tarafından Vanlıyım ve Ailemde
genellikle anerkil Bir ailem olduğunu
düşünürüm pek çok güçlü kadın vardır Hep
beraber
afet bölgesinde yaşayan Akrabalarımız
arkadaşlarımız ve insanlar için yardım
kolileri hazırlamaya koşuşmuştuk deprem
haberini aldıktan sonra onca kadın bir
araya geldik yemekler toparladık
konserve yiyecekler oyuncaklar
battaniyeler ne düşünürseniz her şeyi
yardım kolilerine doldurduk ve afet
bölgesine gönderdik 2 gün sonra aklımıza
şu geldi Hiçbirimiz o kolilere hijyenik
ped ya da tampon koymayı düşünmemiştik
hem de o kadar kadın bir arada olmamıza
rağmen
orada benim kafamda bir soru işareti
oluştu çok garipsedim burada kadın bir
aradayız biz bunu niye konuşmuyoruz
sanki kadın bedenleri bir anda doğal bir
afet olduğu zaman duruyor ve rengi
deneyimi devam etmiyormuş gibiydi ama
hemencecik bunu fark ettikten sonra
yardım kolilerine birkaç tane yenisini
ekledik ve menstral Ürünleri paketleyip
gönderdik yine de bu benimle kaldı
Birkaç yıl sonra hukuk fakültesine
gitmeye başlamıştım Artık sosyal medyada
bir paylaşım gördüm paylaşım şu andaydı
bir Kurumu sözlüğünde bir değişikliğe
gitmiş ve kirli kelimesinin
anlamlarından Birine bir yenisini
eklemişti
bildiğimiz temiz olmayan tanımı
ay başındaki kadın tanımı şimdi bu
sözlükteki bu tanımı okuyan küçük bir
kız çocuğunun kendi bedeni hakkında ve
gelecekte yaşayacağı deneyimler hakkında
ne düşüneceğini tahmin edebilirsiniz
Muhtemelen bu bu Sizler Dinlediğiniz
zamanda internetten girip bu bu saçma
absür tanımın hala orada olduğunu
görebilirsiniz regl olmak kesinlikle
kirli değildir ve Utanılacak bir şey
değildir bizim mücadelemizde tamamen
Bununla ilgili işte benim O Van
depreminden olan alanım ve kirli
kelimesinin tanımlarından biriyle ilgili
olan anlamı bir anda birleşti ve Ben
kafama şunu koydum ben buraya bir
meselesini biraz kurcalayacağım galiba
biraz araştırmak istiyorum niye biz bu
hiç yokmuş gibi davranıyoruz niye hiç
konuşmuyoruz niye hiç düşünmüyoruz niye
hep gölgelerde sessizce yaşamamız
gereken bir deneyimmiş gibi davranıyoruz
diye sorgulamaya başladım ve araştırmaya
giriştim
bu dönemde aynı zamanda G20 zirvesinin
genç kadınlar için düzenlemiş olduğu bir
insiyatife seçildim ve burs olarak Çine
Pekin'e gittim Hatta bazen Çok dalga
geçerim benim feminiz uyanışım için
tarçın seddi'ne gitmem gerekiyormuş diye
Aslında hiç de gerekmiyormuş ama orada
kadın hakları konusunda inisiyatifler
yaratmak isteyen insanlar nelere dikkat
etmeli gibi konularda eğitimler aldığım
bir 15 gün geçirdim ve Pekin İstanbul
dönüş uçağında kafama koydum ben
Türkiye'de regl ile ilgili renkli
tabusuyla ilgili renk yoksulluğuyla
ilgili ki o zamanlar bu tanımın farkında
bile değildim sadece sorunun
farkındaydım Ben bununla ilgili bir
şeyler yapacağım kararını almıştım O
Uçak yolculuğunda
Türkiye'ye geri döndüğümüzde çok çok
mütevazı bir başlangıcı oldu aslında bu
hiçbir zaman şu anda Evet çok büyüdük ve
güzel bir etki yaratabiliyoruz ama
aslında bu benim mezun olduğum lisenin
öğrencileri ile birlikte kek börek
kermesi yapmamla ve ondan
biriktirdiğimiz parayla ilk saat
çalışmamızı düzenlememizle başladı baya
bir bildiğimiz muffinler pişirdik
hamurlar açtık börekler yaptık ve onları
arkadaşlarımıza satıp oradan
kazandığımız parayla Ankara'da Mamak
diye bir ilçe vardır ve bu ilçenin pek
çok gecekondu Mahallesi vardır Bu
gecekondu mahallelerinden birinde bir
saha çalışması gerçekleştirdik Bu saat
çalışmasında Tabii ki doktorlarla
birlikte çalıştık ve
okullara giden öğrencilere regl olmak ve
ergenlik konularında detaylı eğitimler
verdik ve onlara menstral ürünler de
sağladık bir sömestr boyunca
üretebilecek kadar sosyal medyada bu
çalışmayı paylaştıktan hemen sonra bana
Bahar ismini
kavga da yüksek lisans çalışmalarını
yapıyordu Türkiye ilk kadınların evlilik
öncesi cinsel deneyimlerini
araştırdığını ve konuyla çok
ilgilendiğini kendisinin de Adanalı
olduğunu ve benim bu çalışmalarımı ortak
olmak istediğine ve
mevsim tarım işçilerine ulaşma konusunda
yardımcı olabileceğini söyledi ve bizim
böyle baharla Artık hayat ortaklığına
ortaklığa dönüşmüş bir
dostluğumuz başladı diyeyim tamamen
internet üzerinde görüştük aylarca dev
bir saha çalışması planladık ve ilk
büyük saat çalışmamızı Evet bu tesadüfe
kesinlikle tasarlamadık Ama Adana'nın
Yumurtalık ilçesinde gerçekleştirdik
burada mevsimlik tarım işlerine ulaştık
binlerce mevsim tarım işçisine ulaştık
ve yavaş yavaş artık konuşmamız gereği
Misyonu ve neler yapmaya çalıştığımız
nelerle mücadele ettiğiniz yavaş yavaş
ortaya çıkmaya başladı Konuşmamız gerek
Derneği olarak bugüne kadar 50 binden
fazla faydalanıcıya ulaştık genellikle
çalıştığımız gruplar
köy okullarına giden çocuklar mevsim
tarım işçileri ve mülteciler bu gruplara
öncelik veriyoruz Fakat aslında sosyal
ekonomik bakımdan dezavantajlı
mahallelerde yaşayan insanlar reglokslu
deneyimleyen ya da re kitabı suyla
boğuşan herkesin yanındayız ve bununla
ciddi bir mücadele veriyoruz Peki bu
reglokslu problemi gerçekten büyük bir
problem mi Bizim sık sık karşılaştığımız
bir soru bu bazen Birlik şehirlerde
ayrıcalıklı dünyalarımızda çok da hesap
etmediğimiz bir masraf olabiliyor
menstral ürünlere harcadığımız para Ama
gerçekten özellikle son dönemlerde Hayat
pahalılığının da yanında menstral
ürünlerin çok ciddi şekilde
pahalılaştığını ve Örneğin işsizlik
maaşıyla geçirmeye çalışan kayıt dışı
çalışan mevsimlik tarım işçilerinin ya
da düzenli bir geliri olmayan insanların
gözünde Bu ürünlerin tamamen lüks hale
geldiğini görüyoruz
Peki Türkiye'de Bununla ilgili hiç verim
var mı Yani bu gerçekten ne kadar büyük
bir problem diye soracak olursanız
aslında Bazı veriler var mesela derin
yoksulluk dağının bu konuda yapılmış çok
güzel bir çalışması var derin yoksulluk
deneyimleyen 103 haneyle görüştükleri
zaman pandemi döneminde Bu hanelerin
yüzde seksen ikisi dışarıdan yardım
almadığı müddetçe hijyenik ve de hiçbir
şekilde erişimlerinin olmadığını
paylaştılar ve biz de yıllardır bu
konuda araştırmalar yürüttüğümüz halde
bu konuda bir veri eksikliği olduğunu
fark edip Türkiye'nin ilk kapsamlı
regloksuzluğu araştırmasını
gerçekleştirdik ve bazı ön verilerini
yayınlamaya başladık Aslında bu
araştırmamıza Türkiye'nin 81 ilinden
insan katıldı ve 4.499 regl olan birey
katıldı bunlardan öğrendiğimiz çok çok
ciddi problemler oldu yüzde 23'ünün bu
araştırmamıza katılan insanların yüzde
23'ünün regl ürünleri alırken sıklıkla
madde zorluk yaşadığını öğrendik
katılımcıların %10'unun mensural
ürünleri erişim sıkıntısı çektiğini
yüzde yirmi altısının kendilerine ait
güvenli bir tuvaleti erişemediklerini ve
katılımcıların özellikle menstral ürün
almaya paralarının yetmediği dönemlerde
ya da erişimsizlik sıkıntısı çektiği
dönemlerde bebek bezlerinin
kullanılmamış bölümleri tuvalet kağıdı
gazete kağıdı yapraklar veya düzgün
dezenfekte edilemeyen paçavra olarak
kullandığını öğrendik bunu hem
araştırmamızdan hem de Anadolu'nun dört
bir köşesinde Yüz yüze konuşma fırsatı
bulduğumuz regl olan bireylerden
öğrendik Tabii ki böyle ürünlerin
kullanılması menstral ürünler yerine
böyle alternatifler kullanılması başta
vajinal enfeksiyonlar olmak üzere Çok
ciddi sağlık problemlerine sebep
olabiliyor işte biz bu yüzden menstral
ürünleri Erişime bir insan hakkı
olduğunu savunuyoruz Yani bu
regloksluluğu daha ilk başta biraz niş
bir problem gibi gelebilir ama bu hem
bir toplumsal cinsiyet eşitsizliği
sorunu hem de bir derin yoksunluk sorunu
ve biz bununla mücadele yapmaya
çalışıyoruz elimizden geldiğince Bu
arada Türkiye'den örnekler verdik ama bu
aslında Global bir problem Örneğin
Unesco'nun ve unicef'in ortaklaşa
verilerine göre
Afrika'daki
Sahra altı Afrika'daki her 10 kız
çocuğundan biri menstral ürünleri
erişimsizlik sorunları sebebiyle okula
devam edemiyor ve çok ciddi devamsızlık
sorunları yaşıyorlar yine aynı verilere
göre Hindistan'da regl olan bireylerin
%12'si hayatları boyunca menstral
ürünlere hiç erişim sağlayamıyor aynı
şekilde Çok yakın bir zamanda
yöneticilerin Türkiye'deki araştırmaları
da şunu gösteriyor özellikle Türkiye'de
yaşayan Suriyeli mültecilerin hijyenik
ped gibi mensurel ürünleri erişimsizlik
sıkıntıları sebebiyle vajinal
enfeksiyonlar gibi Çok ciddi sağlık
problemleri yaşamaya başladığını
gözlemliyoruz Anlayacağınız üzere
menstral ürünleri erişim sağlık hakkıyla
da çok yakından bağlantılı bir insan
hakkı Biz bunu asla bir hayır işi gibi
görmüyoruz insanlara yardım destek gibi
görmüyoruz bir hak savunuculuğu
yaptığımızı düşünüyoruz açıkçası Peki
regloksuluğunun sebepleri neler çok
hızlıca ondan da bahsetmek isterim
regloksluluğunun en önemli sebeplerinden
biri bu ürünlerin hijyenik Periler Gibi
tamponlar Gibi Bu ürünlerin Çok yüksek
bir şekilde vergilendirilmesi sadece
Türkiye'de değil dünyanın dört bir
tarafında Aslında 20 yüzyılın başından
beri kullandığımız modern menstral
ürünler sanki lüks bir tüketim ürünüymüş
gibi bir makyaj malzemesiymiş gibi çok
pahalı bir parfümmüş gibi
vergilendirildi bu size biraz garip
gelebilir Çünkü regl olan bireyler
olarak bizim bu ürünleri Bu dönemlerde
kullanmamız gerekiyor Bu ürünleri
kullanmamak gibi bir alternatifimiz yok
ve bu ürün lüks bir tüketim ürünü değil
ama ne yazık ki Dünyada ve Türkiye'de
karar alma mekanizmalarındaki İnsanların
büyük bir çoğunluğunu regl olmayan
erkekler olduğu için Bu ürünün ne kadar
enteresan bir ihtiyaç olduğu bir türlü
anlaşılamamış ve yıllarca olabilecek en
yüksek vergi oranlarıyla
vergilendirilmiş ne yazık ki Türkiye'de
de mensureli ürünler %18 katına değer
vergisi ile vergilendiriliyor şöyle
ifade edeyim Türkiye'de bir tüketiciden
devletin alabildiği en yüksek katma
değer vergisi oranı bu yani lüks
yatlardan ve havyardan daha pahalıya
vergilendirilen menstral ürünler
kullanmak zorundayız Biz biraz da Bunu
değiştirmeye çalışıyoruz kesinlikle
Çünkü regloksuzluğunun ve reglunun
ortadan kalkması için politika
değişiklikleri de gerekiyor ve biz bu
alanda mücadelemize devam ediyoruz
bugüne kadar Türkiye'den 3 Cesur kadın
milletvekili regloksulluğu ile mücadele
için bu vergilerin normale düşürülmesi
ve renk kitabı ile mücadele için harika
kanun teklifleri verdi ve onu umut
ediyoruz biz bu konuda türkiye’de ciddi
politika değişiklikleri göreceğiz
ileride bundan 10 yıl önce renkli olma
deneyimleri ya da menstral ürünleri
erişim konuşulmaz isken artık
konuşulmaya başlandığını ve bunun
kamusal alanını taşındığını görüyoruz Bu
da bizim için en büyük mutluluklardan
biri ve bunun dünyada da bir küresel
mücadele haline geldiğini görüyoruz
2004 yılında Kenya'nın mensural
ürünlerden aldığı vergiyi tamamen
kaldırmasıyla başladı Aslında bu serüven
Kenya'nın öncülüğünden sonra Hindistan
Malezya Kanada gibi ülkeler son yıllarda
Avrupa Birliğine üye devletler ve
ABD'nin bazı eyaletleri mensural
ürünlerden aldıkları vergiyi tamamen
kaldırdılar veya çok çok düşük oranlara
indirdiler Bizim de Türkiye için umut
ettiğimiz gelecek bu şekilde Bu sayede
mensurel ürünleri erişimin çok daha
yaygınlaşabileceğini herkesin erişimine
açık olabileceğine inanıyoruz Tabii ki
sadece vergiden ibaret bir mesele değil
bu en önemlisi
çocukların kız çocuklarının bu konuda
çok hazırlıksız bir şekilde büyüdüğünü
regl deneyimimi hakkında kimseyle
konuşamadıklarını ailelerinden
annelerinden veya okulda
öğretmenlerinden bu konuda açık ve doğru
bilgi edinemediklerimi iç çamaşırlarında
ilk defa kan gördüklerinde öleceklerini
zannettiklerini görüyoruz bize
Anadolu'da gerçekleştirdiğimiz saat
çalışmalarında o kadar çok çocuk regl
olmak günah mıdır hocam diye soruyor ki
o kadar o kadar itilmiş o kadar
karanlıkta bırakılmış o kadar
konuşulmamış bir konu ki küçücük bir
çocuğun gözünde Aslında regl gibi çok
normal ve çok sağlıklı bir biyolojik
deneyim Günah Gibi kodlanabiliyor biz de
biraz bunu değiştirmeye çalışıyoruz ve
bu yüzden Konuşmamız gerek diyoruz her
mektubumuzu her konuşmamızı her
buluşmamızı sevgiyle dayanışarak ve
konuşarak diye bitiriyoruz dilerim
herkese menstral elimle
ürünlere erişiminin olduğu ve R
kitabı'sunun regloksuluğunun ortadan
kalktığı bir gelecek için mücadelemize
Sizler de katılırsınız ve Gelecekte bu
sorun ortadan kalkar Biz
ortam baharla birlikte ve Türkiye'nin
dört bir yanındaki destekçilerimiz ve
gönüllülerimizle birlikte bilime dayalı
verilere dayalı bir şekilde bu
mücadeleyi sürdürüyoruz
bu mücadeleye sizin de katılmanız ve bu
bu mücadeleyi regl olmayı regloksuluğunu
konuşabileceğimiz alanlar yaratmaya
devam etmek istiyoruz o yüzden ben de
geleneğe uyuyorum ve bu güzel konuşmayı
sevgiyle dayanışarak ve konuşarak diye
bitiriyorum beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim